Boxing has massively helped
my mental health.
Most of the people here
probably wouldn’t even have jobs
if they didn’t go here
because they wouldn’t
have the right state of mind.
It helps create that
sense of belonging.
Without it, I don’t know
where I would be
Taking part
in any physical activity regularly
will positively impact on a person’s
physical and mental wellbeing.
Boxing has really high
physical demands,
so if a young person engages in
boxing training on a regular basis
and they put the effort in,
they’ll probably see improved
muscular strength,
improved muscular power
and improvements
in their anaerobic fitness.
Boxing has massively disciplined me,
I’ve lost 10 kilos in weight, I’ve
been eating healthy, I haven’t drunk.
Boxing keeps me focused,
it keeps me fit, it keeps me healthy,
body and mind.
Boxing can also alleviate some of the
symptoms of anxiety and depression.
The Bulldogs is a boxing gym
based in Port Talbot.
We’re here to support
the local community.
We’ve got people from all
walks of life, different backgrounds,
we’ve got people who
are disengaged with society,
some people who
are disengaged with school,
and some people who have been
on the wrong side of the law.
It helps create a sense of identity
though attending a gym
and training with others,
and overall it helps create
that sense of belonging.
The benefits of boxing
incorporate things
such as co-operation
and teamwork.
Even though boxing
may seem an individual sport,
it very much involves working
with a coach or a group of coaches
as well as other people
within a gym.
And ultimately it’s really a place to
re-instil some discipline into them,
and put them back
on the straight and narrow.
I’ve lived in Port Talbot
my whole life.
There’s a lot of misconceptions
about Port Talbot,
they talk about the steelworks,
or the air, or this, or that,
there’s not much opportunity here.
But there’s a lot of talent,
there's a lot of sport,
and there is a sense
of community here.
What happens with most boys,
what happened to me,
16, 17, I got in with the
wrong crowd, started drinking,
started doing this and that,
I sort of lost my way.
I see some of the issues with Sam
as being like I see myself in him,
struggling, really,
for somewhere to go,
somewhere to see, and probably
somewhere to feel accepted.
So it’s very important to be able to
build and gain the trust and respect
of the young individuals
who come here.
It’s about being available,
it’s about mentoring,
coaching, empowering,
and also developing their needs,
because a lot
of these young people
haven’t actually been able
to trust people before.
We all respect the coaches,
because we want them to coach us,
and not for them
to shout at us and kick us out.
The people in here are like a family
that I’ve never met before.
So you’re like really close to them,
no matter what,
they can talk to you,
even if you’re feeling down,
and they’ve always got your back.
Some people feel that it can actually
increase aggression and violence,
but research shows that it actually
has the opposite effect,
so it teaches young people
to react differently
in situations that would normally
trigger the anger
and these stress responses.
Obviously with a sport like boxing
there’s the risks of physical injury,
particularly when you’re sparring and
particularly when you’re competing.
However, one could argue
that the benefits
do actually outweigh these risks.
Boxing has massively disciplined me,
it’s made me work hard, resilient,
core values you need in your life
to progress.
They come here,
they can speak to people,
they can let their frustrations go
and really have a different
outlook and perspective on life.
I feel it's very important.
And that sense of identity can extend
beyond the boxing gym,
so not just to the gym itself,
but also to the wider community,
and the wider town, village or
society where that individual lives.
The Bulldogs has given me my first
opportunity to be a leader,
a teacher,
and now I’m going on to finish my
degree and be a qualified teacher.